[Music]
so I recently went to one of those
hipster farm-to-table organic
restaurants that I loved I loved and the
food was great but the way the waiters
described the dishes I had no idea what
I was actually ordering has this ever
happened to you
so tonight to help us all out I thought
it'd be fun to have a real-life foodie
on the show to help us decipher those
wordy menu items so please help me
welcome our guest five-star waiter food
blogger mixologist and assistant sous
chef and stay at home
cupcake artist Rick tell Tiano
everybody hi it's actually pronounced
react react
yes but call me Greg so for the occasion
I made you a special cocktail here this
is a hand swizzle ginger sarsaparilla
old fashioned garnished with a demise
cardamom and a muddled basil tapioca rim
sounds incredible yeah taste well sure
they do that was really bad
exactly that's how you know it's good
because it tastes so bad okay so Greg
how are you gonna help us today well
I'll be showing you a dish and you'll
tell me what you think it is this should
help you understand the parlance we use
in fine dining
okay parlance is another word for words
so for your first course in food
education we'll begin with a pallet
invigorate er palette invigorate er like
a first court like an appetizer well
there's one of those things you order at
Chili's no it's not that okay this is a
bouche of the Meuse variety okay I'm
sure you hear the difference so here's
your first course a bouche of the amuse
bright
first course yes this is a salad I know
a salad Pete look at the food okay it's
not a salad it's much more than that
it's more than a salad yes uh-huh
it's what what it what is it this is
quite clearly crispy loose Leafs fainter
painted with a savory peppercorn
frosting and blanketed in a festive
layer of virginal parmesan snowflakes
Hermes young parmesan okay how was I
supposed to know that that's what this
was it looks like a salad okay well when
you learn to appreciate food Pete and
you know you you will someday
you know just know that food is like
love but it's better because you could
eat it and love is garbage okay so
here's your second of course let's do
another one Greg okay
this has to be a PB&J that's a peanut
butter and jelly sandwiches people think
about what you're saying before you say
it okay you're embarrassing yourself in
front of me in front of the audience in
front of the food Greg this is a PB&J I
smell it
that's a peanut butter and jelly
sandwich just like mom used to make your
mom did not make this unless your mom
was James Beard renowned chef and food
writer James but it was very funny okay
this is a multi legume mash thrusting
itself inside it's liquefied elderberry
lover hidden in the warmth yeasty
privacy and comfort of to wheat duvets
what a multi legume mash thrusting its
own inside I heard you weep
yes weep two days yes two days
yes duvets these are do they wait two
days these are wheat two days I've never
seen someone say wheat like that well
then you've never seen someone pronounce
the word tweet properly
how was I supposed to know that home and
that is impossible you should be able to
taste it I haven't tasted it you've just
put it on a table but tasting you don't
have to bite it to taste it okay you
taste with all of your senses you taste
with your nose you taste with your eyes
I'm tasting you right now and you need a
little bit of salt and some parmesan
okay so now let's move on to the third
course this is a very special one that I
prepared correct yes you if that that's
not a carrot I'm gonna burn down your
childhood home good luck good luck
finding it coz I moved around a lot okay
but this is this is no this is no carrot
it's not even close to a carrot that's
insulting this hmm
be careful please what is this this is a
solar plumped beta-carotene infused soil
rod hand selected and reversed pushed
from the earth bathed served horizontal
and nude soil right this is a solar
solar plumped beta carotene infused soil
rock reverse pushed reversed pushed from
the earth you mean a grill come there
this was reverse pushed can I at least
can I tell you about my restaurant
please come to let petites pork and
Brooklyn it's an old now and continues
on the boats all my
you
[Music]